[Music]
so this is games to know by heart and
generally I think a lot of games from
the distant past are being presented in
this class but I think we should
definitely know by heart games that have
been played in the past but also recent
games between strong opponents and in
tonight's class I want to present the
game between probably the most in-shape
player at the moment and that is can
somebody guess yes lever onion
absolutely he's been winning tournament
after tournament he won a tournament in
st. Louis the st. Louise rapid and
blades I think just a few months ago and
then he continued his very very powerful
year by winning the World Cup and
qualifying for the for the candidates in
quite a fashion so he's been having a
tremendous year he deserves it he's a
very strong player very creative player
as well and part of that creativity we
will just explore in this game but
generally you need to for a dance and
his dance partner was Orca denied each
who is a German Grandmaster very strong
German Grandmaster not top level such as
huronian but he's still a very very
powerful very ingenious 2700 aggressive
he he's not afraid of anybody so he's
he's not a bad player at all so let's
see how this players played c4 e6
g3 we're already seeing some sort of
strange-looking move order of course
we're not seeing the classical d4 we're
seeing more or less and not out of style
approach because recently white players
are start are trying to get some sort of
offbeat
lines on the board get their opponents
out of theory early on and then just be
more familiar with the ensuing endgame
and this is what Aronian does very very
well because he has an army of seconds
behind him so they're just feeding him
continuous ideas every single game he's
coming with a different idea he's very
versatile he knows a lot of structures
but he's also one of the best supported
in terms of team players in the world he
has a huge team behind him so always
fresh ideas d5 Bishop g2 Knight f6
Knight f3 I think I've played this as
well quite recently at least in some
training games if I'm not mistaken he
takes c4 castle
Knight d7 Queen to c2 and now black
decided black decided to place c5 which
I don't necessarily think is the best
move I think he should have tried to
defend that pawn at all costs
with the move
I was I was a kind of setting up a trap
there Knight b6 b5 is quite easily
refuted uh I don't think it's I don't
think it's something well known but it's
quite easily calculated it's two moves
only so what what do you play no yes
somebody
94 absolutely 94 opening up the diagonal
attacking the pawn on d5 now you have a
few options probably if you go Ruby 896
this is game over you can resign on the
spot the queen is lost not the rook the
Queen and if you don't go rook b8 you
have to go something like 95 I think
it's the only other move to save that
look from a8 but then I just take on b5
your c4 is going to hang it's quite
obvious i I think objectively black is
almost lost yeah so no beef I would be
would be a bad move Knight b6 just a
very regular defense you're also kind of
getting your night out of the way the
bishop is ready to perhaps find greener
pastures on c6 that's actually your
worst problem in this type of in this
type of structures the light square
bishop in the catalan this is actually
what we call the Catalan Bishop because
very often he he gets locked up on c8
and is going to be very very difficult
to get him out despite the very very
symmetrical structures quite often this
Bishop on c8 is going to be the
differentiator
which will give white the advantage so
one of his one of blacks main plan is to
go Bishop d7 Bishop c6 Knight b6 would
have been better and the question is how
to continue here how are we going to
take back our pawn it's not that easy
it's not that easy and you have a few
ways if you if you go on 85 I think
Queen d4 is actually quite unpleasant
the night leaves from f3 the d4 square
becomes available and that just helps me
with defending the c4 pawn as well so 95
is not really an option at least not a
good one night a3 definitely an option
but I think blacks should just take on
a3 eliminate that that night we're going
to be a pawn up but obviously why it has
some compensation because of dark square
bishop so long-term initiative for white
he's going to place his Bishop on b2 on
the long diagonal this Knight is kind of
restricted he's going to have to stay
there 2 o'clock 2 o'clock is that this
diagonal not this one this one so after
something like yeah so this should be to
Bishop d7 95 my Bishop b5 very
complicated position I would say yeah
White has compensation I don't know if
full compensation I wouldn't say he has
full conversation so instead of 93 I
think a little bit better would be to do
what can somebody guess or understand
how are you going to keep developing
because you either you kind of have to
get this Bishop out right so in order to
do that you either play d3 or b3 and
that's just going to eliminate my
weakness on c4 that's the bigger problem
so developing sure if if if we could
place this Bishop on e3 directly that
would be very nice
unfortunately oops that's not possible
but yeah that's that's the big problem
yet that pawn on c4 is kind of like a
wedge in our position
we can potentially obtain a similar
position to the one we analyzed after 93
but an improved version where is the
improved version hmm a four a five and
then night a three and then we can route
we can take back with the rook we don't
have to mess our structure so yes a for
forcing a fight because if you allow me
to play five then your knight will have
to go away I'm going to regain the pawn
on c4 and my position is going to be
superior so you have to play a 593
Bishop takes a three rook takes a three
and I think this is a recent game
between way from China and former world
champion ponomaryov I think he was in
like 2000 something I don't remember
exactly one 2004 if I'm not mistaken but
when the format was a little bit
different so cast only for I think this
was played in that game he 590 XT 524
complicated position still very
complicated it's it's not as easy to
assign a clear assessment to it white is
not clearly better black is definitely
not clearly better so it's a very
complex middle game whoever knows the
position whoever is the better player is
going to prevail but yeah I think Knight
b6 is definitely superior to c5 which
was the game continuation Knight a 395
another inaccuracy rook b8 was actually
better in this position and after Knight
c4 maybe Knights maybe B 5 and then
Bishop d7 try to get the bishop power
from c8 out as soon as possible that's
one of the main things you need to do in
this type of structures with black you
have to get this Bishop from C it out if
you manage to activate that bishop and
not fall behind in development
then you're going to be perfectly fine
yeah so rugby 8 was necessary he played
the move 95 Knight takes e4 b5 he's
trying to do that the problem is that
the rook is on the long diagonal Knight
e3 everything will be played with tempo
right now it's very important for white
to play everything
excuse me everything with tempo to not
allow black any breathing room bishop to
be 790 XD 5 what would you take with
with a bishop yes I'm hearing some some
taking with ania take away the pond
would be terrible big big strategical
mistake because your Bishop on b7 is
just going to be locked what would be a
good move in this position actually I'm
quite curious Queen a5 is is aggressive
it's very aggressive but after Bishop e7
mm-hmm the problem is you're you're
focusing on on the idea of not allowing
him to castle but you're not improving
your pieces necessarily and I think
you're kind of helping me to improve
mine so I'm not sure if I'm going to go
to f6 or b6
9:35 and then I Castle and suddenly I
finish my development
so you have to be very careful don't
lose don't don't lose time don't try to
think and kind of how do you call it try
to think of your opponent's best
response do not do not put your eggs in
all in one basket and that is not
allowing him to castle because he's
going to he's going to do that one word
the other yeah and then you're just
simply going to lose your advantage your
Bishop on h3 is definitely not superior
the bishop on g2 the Queen on f5 is a
little bit too advanced maybe at the
right moment I'm even going to be able
to make space for my king and also
attack the Queen gain some tempo with g6
so it's doable but I think in this
position we have to adopt a more
strategical approach
there is no place for what not
necessarily dynamics but I think right
now we have to go for the structural
advantage because his pawns are
overextended on the queenside
let's take advantage of that which one
before before is the best move yes
before pawn sacrifice and after Bishop
b2 we're kind of playing with yes the
same idea that you have that of not
allowing him to castle but I think this
is a much more effective way of doing
that because in the same time we were
finishing our development we place our
pieces on the right squares yeah we
place our pieces on the right squares we
completely shattered his structure this
d4 square is going to be huge in the
future the bishop is always going to be
locked and his extra pawn doesn't really
matter that much right and I think in
order to be able to castle right now he
actually has to make some more
concessions and that is like f6 yeah and
that looks very ugly because suddenly
this is six square becomes available
maybe we can go Knight d4 now yeah or
Lucchesi one or I mean there's plenty of
ways to amass quite quite a nice
advantage in this position so yeah
it takes d5 is a strategical mistake you
have to be very careful when you're
overextending in the center like that
and with when you don't have if the pond
would be on b6 instead of b5 the quiet I
mean it would be a completely different
story
yeah because I don't have to weaken my
dark squares in the center with the pond
on b6 I can just simply stay there and
whenever you play before I'm going to
play some like Bishop e7 finish finish
my development and whenever you take on
c5 I'm retaking back with the pot yeah
I'm maintaining the structure in the
center but after it takes if I before
with the pawn on d5 that's not possible
and you're simply losing strategically
so Bishop takes d5 has to be played if
for Bishop d7 d4 they take rook c8 Queen
e2 and what I want you to pay close
attention is how our own yin doesn't
lose a single temple in this upcoming
sequence of moves a single temple every
single move has a purpose behind it
because if you wouldn't have a purpose
behind every move any if you wouldn't
maintain your precision black would
equalize very very quickly
he would play Bishop e7 Castle them
start exchanging pieces symmetrical
structure you're probably going to be
forced to accept the draw very quickly
but let's see how our onion plays rook
to d1 natural so far yeah putting the
rock on the open file the Queen on d8
seems a little bit misplaced Bishop to
c5
can some type can somebody try to guess
the moves everything with tempo
remember an IB treat very good Bishop to
e7 and this is actually one of the moves
I was most impressed with when I was
watching this game because it's um it's
an idea I haven't I personally haven't
seen it before at least it's not
something out of the ordinary it's just
a little bit unnatural and
counterintuitive in this particular case
but once you see it you kind of
understand it
Bishop d2 would definitely be quite
interesting the problem is I'm going to
castle Bishop a5 and then I go Queen e8
and despite the fact that my position
looks a little bit cramped I'm going to
play Knight c5 next move I'm going to
start exchanging pieces and you don't
have any entry squares yeah it might be
very close to equality it might be very
close to equality
again it's slippery this this type of
structures this type of symmetrical
structures if you don't manage to
maintain your your dynamic dynamic ideas
in the position you're going to lose
your advantage very quickly as white
very very slippery so be sharply - is
interesting but go a little bit further
than then then one move and one idea and
you will understand that it's not as
that effective that's my plan as black I
want to play castle Queen e8 and move my
knight Queen g4 I would I would play
castle and then Bishop f6
hahaha that's an interesting line
actually that's a very interesting line
but I think at the end of it I'm going
to be fine so what I was calculating as
you were mentioning Quincy for quite
interesting move
Castle Bishop h6 I'm not sure I might be
busted and now if I was calculating
that's the thing Knight eggs yeah yeah
rook takes d8 Knight xg4 will take the
fate rook takes the fate Bishop takes b7
I take this guy and I think we liquidate
to draw yeah well I think we're getting
this guy and something I mean why it
might still have a very slight class
because this Knight is a little bit out
of the game and maybe you can well
actually no I'm going to play this move
Bishop a3 very important move to keep
your porn on a - and I'm bringing my
night out this should be equal they
should definitely be equal yeah
I might I might have made some some
mistakes I don't know it's very possible
but I don't think so because he didn't
play Quincy for either so I'm gonna
trust huronian he's a trustworthy guy
also I'm thinking maybe queen no no
queen g4 I was thinking going Bishop f6
directly but I think now if I should
work
I exchanged I exchanged the bishops I
would gladly exchange a bishops black
would be very happy to exchange the
bishops take my queen out of that
annoying pin attack the pawn on e5
replace the bishop on b7 most probably
at the right moment with the queen
correct actually I'm starting to prefer
black I'm starting to think black is
slightly better so know the movies route
d3 very cute little move and very simple
because right now if you go castle I'm
going Queen d1 it's easy as that if you
go Queen c7 I go Bishop f4 which was
played in the game as we will see in
just a second the problem is is going to
is going to be very difficult for you to
get off that bind but only because my
rook is in front of the Queen if the
Queen would be in front them Knight
could jump wherever he wants
but this rook d3 looks I mean when I saw
it I you know understood it immediately
but it it kind of aesthetically pleased
me because I haven't seen this this
pattern before Queen c7 and and and also
what I appreciated was the forcefulness
and of just imposing his ideas on his
opponent not allowing him to go short
castle at all costs
otherwise if you allow him in he's just
going to equalize and with every single
move he's trying to prevent that hey
there is absolutely no move I mean he
could have played Bishop e3 yeah
just a regular move or Bishop a4 but
then just castle in Queenie
I'm surviving that's what he understood
very well understood and effectively
communicated to the position rook d3
very nice book which I paid for 95 rooks
III Roxy one is actually a little bit
more conclusive I think but it's not
that no it's not that easy to calculate
so for example after after queen bee ape
you have to you have to see Roxy eight
Bishop takes c8 and now I think there is
only one move to maintain a huge
advantage and that is I think 95
threatening knight c6 Queen c7 rock c3
now and the game is over and I think if
you go Bishop deep
what to do now what if what if he goes
if he goes Bishop here I think knight c6
should be more than enough if you take
back with the knight Bishop takes d6 and
your king is never going to castle
anymore
I play e5 next move and the game is over
even better even better yes yes correct
96 game is over 96 Queen c7 loop d8 and
a lot of a lot of extra material yeah so
the position is just I mean the bind is
just too much
in this position he cannot he cannot
escape so I think I'm not really sure
what he missed but he decided to play
rook c3 he lost a little bit of
precision there and it could have costed
him as we will see later on but still I
I think he played a very very beautiful
game Queen h5 everything is with tempo
again notice how everything is with
temple Bishop d6
[Music]
mm not necessarily okay Bishop take c8
what to do
rook d1 everything with tempo 95 very
good very good probably the only move
actually that maintains the initiative
if if you go Castle I think Bishop takes
d5 Bishop takes e5 and knight c6 yeah
and that's just well it's not game over
and actually objectively I think castle
was actually a little bit better but
okay after g6 you're not gonna go Queen
g5 because queen g5 f 6 but Knight XG 6
this is just a simple pawn up yep Queen
retreats back to e2 I'm a pawn up of
course there's going to be some
technical conversion involved and it's
going to last a little bit but white
should be winning of course black was
not willing to accept that so he tried
to you know keep the keep the position
as complicated as possible he played a
move Bishop to d7 alright
let's try to calculate let's try to
calculate of course the first thing that
we should calculate are the force
variations and in in in this particular
instance what is the force variation
Bishop e5 Bishop takes e5 and then
taking advantage of the consequence of
the of blacks last move and there is
Bishop d7 rook takes the 7 kingdoms d7
Queen takes f7 and then he's going to go
King to d6 let's go there let's go there
because this is exactly what he did and
it's extremely difficult to calculate in
a short amount of time I would assume at
this moment I actually don't know I
haven't watched this live but I would
assume this is one of the critical
moments in the position and I I think
our only inspect some time for his
decision
what to do it's not that easy it's
definitely not that easy we don't have
any dark square bishop on the board so
the king is surprisingly fairly safe
fairly safe on d6 97 is is is something
that we will have on tap as we move
along for sure but let's try to
calculate Knight b6 night b7 I'm going
to go cane c6 only move and then I don't
really see the continuation yeah and by
the way precision is still extremely
important you can lose your advantage
very quickly still
hmm any other candidates bishop h3 of
course that's another candidate that's
what he played rookie a and at least
right now the rookies tied as well
yeah the defense of the e6 pawn and the
Queen on b8 is tied to the difference of
the rookin ie8 so let's try to
assimilate all that information and see
what he did
Knight to be seven first now he played
it and he will see in just an instant
why is Bishop h3 rook e8 inclusion was
very important King to c6 if you're at
home you should definitely take some
time and try to find the right right
move at this instance does black
threaten anything he's threatening the
bid to pawn sure anything else
now see try to ignite the rookies
hanging so that's a piece of information
that's extremely important to understand
that the night on p7 is not under attack
how can you improve your position I hear
some interesting ideas from the back
before of course that's the move to
bring your knight wider c5 or to just
solidify the knight on a five big move
big big move because simply your
position was a little bit loose before
now for example I think I'm threatening
no I'm not threatening Bishop takes c6
yet but I am threatening 95 no Knight
sorry Knight a5 I'm threatening right
now and only if you go King d6
so after Knight a5 if you go King b6 I'm
simply going to take the pawn on e6 take
the pawn on e6 I'm going to plant the
bishop on d5 and I'm going to have a
better position and if you go to d6 try
to defend the e6 pawn after Knight a5
then I have the move f4 and then ideas
with e5 your king is also with the
inclusion of this move before your king
is almost trapped almost checkmate
so before is a very powerful move rook
to f8 black is playing very precise as
well very good defensive defensive moves
and in this position objectively I'm
going to show you the best the best
variation from a practical point of view
what Aronian played proved to be to
prove to be enough
nevertheless the engine finds some some
defensive resources along the way and I
think the position could objectively be
considered close to equal though the
best move in this position would have
been I think 95 first and then queen e7
but this is extremely difficult because
after Queen c8 once again if you're at
home pause the video try to find it
yourself
but I I definitely suggest you guys try
to think along very artistic lines
it's interesting I don't know if it does
much I think I can just simply play rook
e8 rook a fate if I really want to I can
repeat the position with rook e8 Queen
f7 and rook a fate I probably have
better ways of dealing with 97 because
it's not doing that much it doesn't have
an active idea behind it
no the the bishop is good on h3
you will include it at the right moment
if your opponent player like placer and
things
but again it's just this move preserves
the advantage everything else allows
black to at least equalize mm-hmm
f4 interesting again it's a liability f4
becomes a liability I Bishop d4 and then
my queen enters play Quincy one or
Quincy to everything we check I actually
think you're you're in trouble there 96
exactly that's the move the Queen cannot
take the trickier part is that after you
take with the king now I take on his six
with the bishop and you don't really
have any moves because if you go here
I'm going to go Bishop d5 and you get
checkmated very tough to see extremely
tough to see and right now with the king
on c6 after rook e8 I have Queen c5 yeah
so I always have some extra ideas with
with the King on c6 very difficult to
very difficult move to see especially
from afar so I mean you cannot really
judge the man for for not finding it you
know so in this position after rook f8
he played the move 27 first
and right now Bishop c7 was probably the
better move still it's just one move
okay after 95 this position is still
extremely difficult for both sides to
play I would say for Black is a little
bit more difficult just because of the
fact his King is so exposed nevertheless
his pieces are getting some sort of
coordination and his King is not as
unsafe so I think objectively this would
have been his best chance instead he
played the move Bishop d6 925 Queen
takes c6
Queen d7 Bishop takes before
96 very natural play and we're just
simply going to enter an opposite color
Bishop endgame 26 Quint xe8 Quinn takes
c6 and let's see how he converted
because as we all know opposite color
Bishop M games are definitely far from
easy
yeah very technical he forced the King
to be a little bit further that's why he
played check yeah he wants to exchange
the Queen's on the B file
III don't know if necessarily actually
it is going to be quite influential
because if we do this he's a little bit
closer and he gets to d4 yeah I think
the position should still be winning
with that being said it would be much
nicer if our King would be on e3 and we
we won't allow the King
the black king to get active so that's
why he played the move Queen to be 8f
for king f2 king of three the point
being you're your majority on the Queen
side doesn't mean anything
blacks majority on the Queen side is
going to be very very easily contained
with the bishop on the e8 a4 diagonal or
with the bishop on the g8 a to that
ha ha ha we'll be dangerous there will
be very dangerous maybe at the right
moment maybe at the right moment if the
position gets very simplified but I
don't think we have to do that because
again he's not going to be able to
create a passport he's definitely not
going to be able to create a passport if
right right if he man if he goes with
the king all the way down to be to loses
a lot of temples and then in the
meantime we start pushing our extra
points then absolutely we will sacrifice
the bishop if necessary and we will be
already very close to promotion if it
doesn't involve his King into into this
attempt at creating a passport on the
Queen side then he is simply not going
to be able to create that passport
because our Bishop is going to be very
powerful on those diagonals h6 creating
some more entry squares oops
but potentially like this yeah Bishop
g6e five
before doesn't work because of Bishop b5
King c6 is first bishop c2 I can I can
contain your pawns from multiple
diagonals yeah King to five Chuck now
I'm transferring my bishop on the c6 on
the Eata for diagonal
you cannot play before if you play a3
I'm immediately going to transfer it on
the g8 a two diagonal and then you're
not going to be able to create a
passport
you cannot approach it with the king
king before king a3 allows me to grab
the pawn on b4 so you're simply
paralyzed your majority is paralyzed
yeah it's completely useless
Bishop to eight King before
centralization everything very smooth
not allowing our opponent any sort of
counter play a3 finally he got bored he
was like okay I'll let you put your
Bishop on on g88 two diagonal I
acknowledge the fact that I have
absolutely nothing to do with that with
that majority on the Queen side so he
was ready to resign basically King goes
back and now my pawns are going to start
rolling 5 6 etc etcetera
game is over black resigned
so I from from the beginning till the
end if you remember from the start of
that move rook to rook to d3 maybe even
actually even before that
efore d for everything with temple
Aronian didn't make a single move
without a concrete plan behind it a very
concrete plan most of them backed by
tactics yeah so be very very careful too
the specific requirements of the
position in in this situation the
specific requirement of the position was
that you have to play very concrete
powerful forced moves that don't allow
your opponent to regroup his forces okay
even when you gave up the exchange yes
even after that I mean if he would have
found 96 that would have been the nicest
move of the year probably but you know
it's not that easy and and and and even
so from a practical point of view the
position was still very difficult to
defend for for black yeah with the King
out out in the open when you're squeezed
like that when when you're always
threatened with checkmates that at every
single move for a prolonged period of
time you know the tension rises and
you're not going to find the best moves
so I think I think we can this year I
would say go back home analyze huronian
gay erroneous games he has plenty of
gems such as this one and and and if you
pay close attention you're going to
learn a lot of things from his games
very creative good player to follow for
sure
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]